[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour bienvenue pour ce numéro spécial
de mode d'emploi nous sommes au
vélodrome nationale à l'occasion de
l'événement en piste pour l'emploi c'est
le rendez vous de saint quentin en
yvelines dédié à l'emploi et à la
formation
focus justement sur l'évolution
professionnelle
alors la vae c'est la validation des
acquis de l'expérience et une façon de
faire reconnaître vos compétences dans
le but d'obtenir un diplôme un titre ou
encore une certification de
qualification professionnelle et avec
tout justement sur ce thème
une experte carolina pedrola bonjour
alors au sein de l'académie de
versailles vous êtes conseillère
validation des acquis de l'expérience
vous êtes également chargé de
communication pour le d'havas le davasse
et le dispositif académique de
validation des acquis alors quelles sont
vos missions
alors les missions du dha va donc
dispositif académique de validation des
acquis consiste à reconnaître et
permettre aux personnes qui peuvent se
lancer dans le projet reconnaître les
compétences de façon à obtenir une
certification un diplôme qui est en
cohérence avec le parcours professionnel
1 c'est donc une mission double mission
la mission de certificateur c'est à dire
chargé d'identifier si le projet et est
possible et puis une autre mission qui
est émission d'accompagnateurs puisque
le d'havas était un organisme certifiés
et labellisés pour justement accompagner
toutes les personnes qui se lancent dans
un projet de ce type donc
essentiellement sur les diplômes de
l'éducation nationale donc du ceap et au
bts mais également sur les diplômes
signé cosigné du travail social 1 c'est
à dire tout ce qui est moniteur
éducateur éducateur spécialisé
donc notre mission académique on est sur
quatre départements
donc les yvelines l'essonne
les hauts-de-seine et donc le 95 nous
avons donc ce set cette charge 7,7 ce
rôle ce ce cette mission qui consiste à
déjà informé on a un rôle d'information
1 pour justement ce dispositif soit
davantage connu parce que tout le monde
ne sait pas quoi on entend parler de
verrues on sait pas forcément
concrètement voilà foresterie à droite
c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire c'est en
tentant que c'est compliqué ils
n'avaient que ces longs que c'est
difficile et en fait c'est toute une
autre histoire
c'est bon ça demande un effort parce que
c'est pas automatique ce n'est pas parce
qu'on a six mois alors la loi vient
juste de changer c'était auparavant
trois ans aujourd'hui c'est 12 mois
d'expérience professionnelle dans un
secteur des filles justement je vais
vous demander les critères justement
pour quelles raisons ces critères doute
pas toute personne qui peut justifier
d'au moins 12 mois d'expérience
professionnelle dans un champ
professionnel défini peut selon les
textes se lancer dans le projet de
validation des acquis donc faut prouver
une activité professionnelle voire même
bénévole dans un cadre associatif et
ça va être une expérience actuelle ou
passée donc passer pas trop passer parce
qu'il faut faire appel à la mémoire et
si l'expérience date d'il ya à dire 5 6
ans ça commence à être difficile mais
pas impossible en soi mais voilà c'est
plus facile lorsque l'expérience et
fraîche ou pas trop en ciel ça dure là
c'est la personne qui se lance dans le
projet qui va décider décider du temps
qui lui est nécessaire
on va dire qu'en moyenne si on tels que
le droit y est c'est durée de six mois
pour monter un dossier
c'est pas seulement démarches
administratives il ya un travail de
rédaction personnel
et puis c'est pas seulement ce travail
de rédaction du fameux mémoire qui
suffit il faut aussi être capable de le
défendre de le présenter c'est une étape
qui ne s'invente pas c'est parfois même
assez pas dit déstabilisant mais je veux
dire sa demande préparation on ne part
pas laventure de la vo sans penser à
cette à cet entretien puisqu'il ya pas
en fait la vae vous demander quels
étaient les les critères 12 voix
effectivement d'expérience
professionnelle minimum avoir des
documents d'identité c'est quand même
assez large comme public
ainsi vous ne pouvez pas justifier de
cette expérience c'est que vous n'avez
pas de papier voilà elle avait ce sera
pas faite pour vous et puis
éventuellement mais ce n'est pas
obligatoire un diplôme dire que la vf
pour sonner différemment de
l'information surtout si vous avez
développé des compétences
professionnelles qui vous permettent de
tenter d'obtenir un bts même si vous
n'avez pas le bac ou même des plots va
frapper bien la vae est envisageable
c'est pas forcément un gage de réussite
totale il y a le jury peut décider d'une
validation partielle ou totale
mais alors là quand même sept candidats
sur 10 en moyenne chaque année sur
l'académie de versailles et même au
niveau national qui obtiennent leur
diplôme par la validation des acquis
donc c'est pas automatique j'insiste sur
le sujet c'est pas un sou diplôme c'est
le même diplôme que celui acquis par la
voie de la formation
alors justement vos côtés quelqu'un qui
a obtenu cette fameuse vae en 2015
david jalbert bonjour vous êtes
auditeurs internes au sein du service
informatique de la banque populaire
ça fait 19 ans que vous êtes dans cette
entreprise donc comme je le disais en
2015 vous avez entrepris de faire une
vae avant de nous dire pourquoi est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire plus déjà
sur votre parcours
scolaire et puis votre parcours
professionnel aussi oui alors moi j'ai
un j'ai une maîtrise de sciences
économiques et je suis passé je suis
arrivé à l'informatique raza au passage
à l'an 2000 à l'euro il ya eu 1
elle devrait un vrai appel d'air sur ces
professions d'informaticiens donc j'ai
commencé comme développeur après je suis
passé
concepteur et puis chef de projet puis
au bout d'un moment dans ma société
moi je me suis aperçu pour évoluer sur
certains postes il fallait mieux avoir
bac + 1 puisque en france ça reste
important de le niveau de diplôme
même si on a de l'expérience à côté et
du coup je me suis dit je vais je vais
convertir ses années d'expérience en
diplôme donc au juste pour une année
supplémentaire mais je trouvais que ça
valait la peine de le faire pour pas
pour être clair vis-à-vis de mes
candidatures
alors comment vous aviez connu justement
ce set cette bo l'existence de la vae en
cherchant sur internet les différentes
façons d'obtenir des diplômes
complémentaire donc j'avais regardé le
cned ou la cnam enfin tout organisme qui
peut permettre aussi d'avoir des
diplômes et la vae g - l'époque c'était
que j'étais chef de projet j'avais déjà
3 ans d'expérience
j'avais l'impression que c'était
compatible donc je me suis rapproché de
mon ancienne faculté qui était panthéon
sorbonne mais panthéon sorbonne
je n'avais pas de site internet dédié
c'est très compliqué d'avoir
l'information
alors comme je travaillais à 50 ans je
me suis pas j'ai regardé l'université de
saint quentin et là c'était beaucoup
plus clair il ya un site dédié y avait
un site dédié il y avait tout
toute une à une présentation de la
proche du calendrier du planning de
possibilités de financement je crois de
mémoire et donc je suis passé par plus
tôt par cette université là d'autant
plus que j'ai trouvé le masters qui
pouvait vraiment collé à mon expérience
alors justement quels diplômes vous avez
obtenu grâce à cette nouvelle donc j'ai
obtenu un master de management
stratégique et changement donc j'avais
pour moi je pensais je j'avais identifié
que je pouvais que à peu près couvrir
70% à peu près de ce masters par rapport
à mon expérience est donc ce qui fait
que j'ai eu une validation partielle en
fait en effet le la présentation du
dossier de validation à l'oral permet
aux jurys d'identifier si si
l'expérience suffit à avoir le diplôme
là il manquait quelques quelques unités
d'enseignement donc j'ai complété mon
travail j'allais dire pour aller
jusqu'aux même un mémoire pour obtenir
cette cette validation totale du v12
laver ça durait combien de temps alors
et c'est à peu près six mois tout à
l'heure vous ça va durer combien de moi
j'ai choisi l'accompagnement de
l'université donc s'il ya six ateliers
de sakho 6 ateliers de trois heures soit
en petit groupe de 5,6 soit individuelle
pour valider chaque étape en fait de du
travail en fait c'est notamment sur le
dossier de le dossier de validation que
vous aviez appelé mémoire tout à l'heure
ça nécessite pas de
d'avoir une épreuve une approche
universitaire donc l'accompagnement
permet justement d'avoir les bons et des
bancs mécanisme en fait de rédaction
pour présenter la problématique pour
présenter l'expérience pour faire un
dossier qui collent aussi aux au masters
qu'on a choisi donc pour présenter
l'expérience en fonction du masters
grâce à cette vae est ce que ça vous a
permis d'évoluer dans votre entreprise
oui tout à fait donc il s'avère ça s'est
fait en parallèle mais j'ai obtenu le
justement j'ai été accepté au poste
d'auditeur interne qui était réservé en
principe au bac +5 et grâce à cette vae
j'ai pu j'ai pu obtenir ce poste
est ce que votre votre employeur était
au courant lorsque vous avez entrepris
cette démarche alors au départ non c'est
vrai que quand j'ai postulé
j'ai indiqué que j'étais en cours de vae
il s'avère que il avait accepté bon
j'avais bac +4 donc il y avait quand
même le delta était faible
il avait avec silva avait embauché
accepté à ce poste avec mon bac + 4 mais
le fait que j'aie eu une vae à éviter
entre guillemets une jurisprudence en
fait justement caroline pedrola est ce
que l'employeur est obligé d'être au
courant quand on quand un salarié
souhaite faire à une vae dont
l'employeur n'est pas obligé d'être
informer le salarié peut se lancer entre
guillemets discrètement dans le projet
l'employeur sera informé si le salarié
demande un congé formation parce que
même s'il n'y a pas de formation
vraiment pour la vae
si on peut si on veut on peut obtenir un
24 heures de congé formation sert de
temps pour être disponible pour venir à
ces rendez-vous justement
qui sont échelonnées échelonné sur
plusieurs mois puisque la durée vous
avez dit plusieurs heures mais en fait
ce sont des rendez-vous qui sont donnés
tous les mois à peu près donc nous on
compte environ à peu près six mois de
détail allemand sur ces différents
créneaux horaires des différents rendez
vous est donc quand il faut s'absenter
de son travail
soit on prend un jour de congé ou de rtt
ou bien il ya aussi ce moyen de demander
un congé formation et c'est là où il
faut en faire la demande à son employeur
et là il devient fort mais ça peut te
convient de faire une vae pardon ça la
cause ça coûtera alors ça coûte
nous sommes nous en tant que
certificateur agréé labellisé tout à
fait réglementée dans les tarifs c'est à
dire qu on se cale sur les tarifs exigés
par les financeurs que ce soit et les
opca ou ou la région donc c'est en
fonction du nombre d'heures que les
tarifs sont plus ou moins importants
mais on va dire vous parle d'une moyenne
petite et de moyenne d'environ 1000
euros ou au maximum 24 heures merci à
tous les deux d'être intervenu sur ce
thème de la vae dans quelques instants
nous allons parler bilan de compétences
[Musique]
lorsque l'on envisage d'évoluer
professionnellement ou bien de se
reconvertir et bien dispositif permet de
faire le point sur ses compétences et
ses objectifs professionnels
cela s'appelle tout simplement bilan de
compétences vous allez entendre des
témoignages mais tout de suite je me
tourne vers anne salvi du cibc 78
bonjour alors vous êtes la directrice 1
du centre interinstitutionnel de bilan
de compétences des yvelines le cibc 78
il est basé à saint germain en laye est
ce que peut nous présentait justement
cet établissement
oui le cibc est une structure parra qui
dépend de l'éducation nationale et nous
sommes nous existons depuis 1992 donc
l'objectif du centre de bilan de
compétences c'est de faire entre autres
des bilans de compétences notre équipe
est composée de consultants psychologue
ou non psychologue et le bilan de
compétences est donc un outil au service
de votre repositionnement professionnel
un outil c'est à dire un espace qui vous
est consacré et au cours duquel vous
allez parler de votre parcours
professionnel vous allez évaluer vos
compétences vos aptitudes vos
motivations
vos intérêts professionnels
pour in fine et construire un projet
professionnel
l'objectif du bilan c'est de construire
un projet de se projeter sait pas rester
statique sur son expérience c'est un
regard en arrière on regarde dans le
rétroviseur ce que vous avez fait pour
se projeter pour préparer sa seconde
partie de carrière pour préparer son
avenir dans l'entreprise aussi voilà
donc le bilan de compétences un outil au
service de votre repositionnement
professionnel
le bilan va durer 24 heures et vous
aurez des des entretiens avec un
consultant des gays alors généralement
quel public viens viens vous voir est ce
que ce sont des séquelles quel public
vient vous voir
nous recevons tous publics cadres et non
cadres en poste et or poste et toute
personne qui a envie de se poser sur sa
carrière et de ceux et de d'avoir un
mouvement réflexif sur sa carrière
1 toute personne qui se posent aussi des
questions sur son avenir professionnel à
certaines dizaines de
de la vie professionnelle 30 ans 40 ans
50 ans on se pose des questions que ce
que j'ai envie de faire qu'est-ce que je
peux faire
qu'est ce que je pourrais faire et c'est
le moment d'y réfléchir et c'est le bon
moyen d'y réfléchir avec un consultant
qui va être le miroir de ce que vous
allez lui apporter à savoir que le bilan
de compétences ça demande beaucoup de
travail personnel
il faut être prêt aussi pour le bilan
prêt à se remettra en cause a revisité
ses réussites
enfin c'est plutôt sympathique aussi à
revisiter ses difficultés
et parfois ces échecs il faut être prêt
toujours dans l'objectif de construire
un projet un projet qui vous ressemble
qui soit réaliste qui soit réalisable
bien évidemment alors justement vos
côtés deux personnes qui ont franchi le
pas justement pour pour faire un bilan
de compétence on va commencer avec avec
vous marie de ré vous venez vous en tout
juste entre justement de démarrer un
bilan de compétences quelle était votre
situation justement avant dans le
d'effectuer cette démarche
alors avant j'étais dans le commerce
alimentaire je travaillais en
boulangerie pâtisserie
jusqu'à décembre 2010 est donc j'ai
besoin de faire un bilan de compétences
je dis bien le mot besoin parce que pour
moi c'est vraiment nécessaire
ça fait 35 ans que je n'étais pas la
recherche d'un emploi depuis janvier de
cette année et qu'on n'est plus sur le
marché du travail
on est un petit peu désorienté un petit
peu faire violence et plus ce qui se
passe donc pour moi le bilan de
compétences est vraiment je le répète
nécessaire pour faire le point sur mes
capacités personnelles sur mes
compétences professionnelles également
j'ai besoin d'une remise à plat de tous
pour l'instant j'en suis au début j'ai
fait
deux fois deux heures plus une heure et
demi de tests que j'aurai les résultats
la prochaine fois je pense justement
c'est quoi comme comme type de tests
qu'on vous demande alors là je pourrais
pas vous dire c'est pas très compliqué
madame madame s'allier à des tests de
rapidité des tests de logique des thèses
de je sais pas trop en quoi ça concerne
le grand jeu pour passer madame c'est
albi qui sert demande pourra mieux
renseignés effectivement dans l'outil
bilan de compétences il ya une partie
tests psychométriques qui permet à la
personne d'avoir son profil
professionnel le tsb psychométrie n'est
pas une vérité intangible en soi le test
est intéressant parce qu'il donne des
repères alors on a le test des intérêts
professionnels
vous l'avez pas encore passé malgré le
test d aptitude cognitive
comment vous recevez l'information et
comment vous là vous allez la restituer
et le test des comportements en milieu
professionnel
donc nous on utilise trois types de
tests mais y en a plein d'autres aussi
alors madame dereck comment vous au parc
et le billet en fait vous avez vous avez
connu l'existence justement du bilan
comme de compétences et bien j'en ai
pris connaissance lors de mon premier
entretien avec ma conseillère à pôle
emploi et vous êtes libre pourquoi pas
oui oui mais j'avais envie de le faire
pour moi c'était très important assez
c'est la première étape pour ensuite
accéder à la recherche d'un emploi alors
qu'est ce que vous attendez concrètement
2 à la fin de ce bilan
j'attends qu'on oriente comme qu'on me
dise exactement de quelle formation j'ai
besoin que vous cherchez vraiment donc à
changer complètement d'orientation
professionnelle a changé complètement
d'orientation donc je voudrais savoir
d'après mon parcours antérieur ce vers
quoi je peux m'orienter exactement et
quelle formation va m'aider à pouvoir
changer
en fait c'est dans le bruit d'une
reconversion professionnelle comme ça
lui vous lire ajouter quelque chose
juste de rajouter
peut-être que j'ai oublié la personne
qui effectue son bilan de compétences
est acteur de son et acteur de son
devenir
c'est pas le bilan qui va dire que c'est
vous la personne qui allait choisir
votre devenir votre avenir professionnel
et le conseiller n'est pas là pour vous
donner une orientation il est là pour
vous donner des idées pour confronter
avec vous mais en aucun cas il ne
prendra une décision à votre place c'est
vous c'est l'acteur c'est le
bénéficiaire qui est acteur à 90% alors
un autre acteur thierry et vous suivez
justement un bilan de compétences et
également lors vous en êtes à
mi-parcours 1 c'est bien ça oui à peu
près sûr que donc le bilan de
compétences se fait envie séance jean
moi j'en ai fait trois pour le moment
mon +22 des fameux tests j'ai envie de
dire le bilan de compétences on n'y va
plus pour avoir des questions que pour
avoir des réponses dans le sens où les
réponses on les a mais on sait pas les
trouver en eux mêmes et les
les gens qui rencontrent nous aide à
nous poser les bonnes questions pour
réellement savoir quelles sont nos
compétences puisque ils savent pas plus
que nous quelles sont nos compétences
c'est nous qui savons mais ils vont nous
aider à les trouver et c'est en ça que
c'est intéressant parce qu'effectivement
comment on entendait tout à l'heure par
rapport à la vae
la dame qui disait qu'il fallait prendre
conscience de ces de ses compétences
c'est un peu aussi le même rôle qu'on a
au niveau du bilan de compétence et de
prendre conscience qu'on a ses
compétences la passe quand on a fait
beaucoup de choses dans nos vies moi
personnellement je me suis bien vingt
ans de carrière et est ensuite un
parcours un accident de parcours je suis
je suis demandeur d'emploi maintenant et
savoir vers quel type de profession je
peux m'orienter quel type de poste
auquel je peux répondre c'est c'est en
ça que le bilan de compétences va
m'aider vous travaillez dans quel
secteur
alors j'ai travaillé dans le secteur de
l'industrie pendant 16 ans et dans le
secteur de l'hôtellerie pendant quatre
ans et donc là vous voulez complètement
vous réorienter professionnellement
parlant pas forcément complètement me
réorienter je les fais déjà il ya quatre
ans l'idée c'est surtout de savoir
est-ce que je continue dans l'hôtellerie
est ce que je retourne dans l'industrie
est ce qu éventuellement jeu mes
compétences peuvent me permettre d'aller
dans un autre domaine mais toujours
en utilisant ses compétences soient
aussi même question qu'ils ont à me dire
et comment vous avez appris l'existence
du bilan de compétences alors moi
personnellement j'avais mon beau frère
qui avait fait un bilan de compétences
pour à titre personnel pour pouvoir voir
un peu ce qu'ils pouvaient faire dans
l'avenir et donc ça m'avait donné idées
plus ou moins et après quand je me suis
retrouvé demandeurs d'emploi moi je me
suis dit que c'était bon moment pour le
faire
concrètement vous attendiez alors vous
disais on n'attend pas forcément des
réponses ont annoncé plus des questions
mais je rejoins madame ça de vie on est
quand même acteur à 90%
les réponses sont les ans nous mêmes et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'il faut faire
preuve d'une grande honnêteté quand on
nous pose des questions parce que le on
veut construire un projet si on veux le
construire convenablement faut le
construire sur des bases solides et il
faut d'abord être honnête avec soi-même
pour pouvoir avoir cette solidité dans
le projet d'avenir et donc moins c'est
madame sa vie qui me suis donc au mans
c'est mon état d'esprit
moi je départ j'ai j'avais conscience
que j'allais être acteur à 90% et je
savais qu'il fallait que je sois
totalement honnête sur mon parcours
professionnel sur les choix que j'ai
fait pourquoi j'ai effet comment je les
ai faits voilà essais ont dit des fois
des choses qu'on n'a pas dit à d'autres
personnes parce que parce que voilà on
fait des choix des fois les vraies
raisons les connaît mais on veut pas les
dire parce que ça nous met pas forcément
bien à l'aise là il faut cesser d
entretiens confidentiels
on sait que ça ne sortira jamais du
bureau et en ça on peut se livrer et le
fait d'être honnête avec soi même ça
nous permet à nous d'avancer
est ce que c'est une manière aussi de
reprendre confiance en soi peut-être a
totalement totalement said alors ça aide
aussi à se mobiliser moi je vois que je
suis à la recherche d'un emploi on est
chez soi
les conseillères pôle emploi
le voir une ou deux fois mois ça fait
quatre mois que je suis un chercheur
d'emploi j'ai vu j'ai vu deux
conseillers différent chez pôle emploi
en est à tout seul à la maison on répond
à des offres d'emploi on a pas mal de
réponses négatives ou pas de réponse
déjà avoir une réponse négative faut
savoir que c'est c'est bien d'avoir une
réponse est donc on a tendance à se
démobiliser et à se perdre un petit peu
dans dans une inactivité
donc ça est déjà à se remobiliser à se
remettre d'un petit coup de pied aux
fesses excusez-moi l'expression mais
voilà il faut qu'on se bouge et ensuite
forcément oui si on reprend confiance en
soi on reprend confiance on a conscience
qu'on est capable de faire des choses et
de se bouger soi même et ça c'est
important
donc pour conclure pour conclure si vous
avez envie de faire un bilan de
compétences c'est une bonne idée pour
vous pour préparer un projet et pour
être prêt à rebondir si vous en avez
besoin
la carrière nenê plus linéaire et pensez
à votre employabilité et si on veut si
vous voulez travailler votre
employabilité faites le en amont en
réfléchissant sur votre parcours sur ce
que vous savez faire ce que vous avez
envie de faire et ce qui est possible de
faire
madame de ré un mois pour conclure un
bilan de compétences
n'est pas forcément nécessaire pour tout
le monde
il est en fonction de sa carrière un
moment donné à un moment précis de sa
carrière et donc si ce moment s'avère il
faut faire c'est très important
thierry un mois pour conclure je dirais
qu'un bilan de compétences est
effectivement dans la position où on est
en tant que demandeur d'emploi c'est
important parce que on a besoin de se
resituer par un parent par rapport à un
marché du travail
moi j'ai aussi des amis qui l'ont fait
en tout en restant en poste et ça leur a
permis d'avoir un meilleur
épanouissement dans l'entreprise sans
changer d'entreprise de vous prendre
peut-être dans des grands postes dans
des grandes entreprises d'autres postes
d'hôtes d'autres orientations
merci à tous les trois en tout cas pour
votre témoignage sur le bilan de
compétences merci
c'est la fin de ce numéro merci de
l'avoir suivi à très bientôt pour un
nouveau mode d'emploi
[Musique]
[Rires]
à